efectivamente sigue la huelga y un 30%
de las gasolineras sigue al menos con
escasez en un tipo de combustible en
este país por eso el gobierno ha
decidido requisicionar esto quiere decir
intervenir obligar a trabajar a los
funcionarios de un tercer depósito el de
faisán está ubicado en el centro del
país en la región de ron cerca de Lyon
yabastece a las regiones de obenia
ronalpes y de borgoña Frances donde la
escasez de combustible estaba superando
un 35%. así lo informó la ministra de
transición añez que se dirigió
directamente a los sindicatos les dijo
estas requisiciones no son contra
ustedes sino que son por todos los
franceses que están sufriendo con esta
huelga y que no están logrando
satisfacer sus necesidades básicas a
raíz de este movimiento ella visitó esta
mañana justamente un Puerto Seco que hay
en el norte de París donde llega la
gasolina que viene del depósito de eso
exo móvil en normandía que fue el
primero que fue requisicionado más lejos
que esta ministra fue el ministro de
economía Bruno lemer que dijo que este
movimiento es ilegítimo él dijo aquí un
acuerdo de salarios mayoritario en total
que fue aprobado por la mayoría sin
embargo y se dirigió al sindicato más
radical más a la izquierda mayoritario
en depósitos y refinerías cgt les dijo a
ellos ustedes están imponiendo la ley de
La minoría y en una democracia la que se
impone es la ley de la mayoría por lo
tanto este movimiento es ilegítimo otro
ministro el del trabajo confirmó que la
situación sigue siendo complicada sobre
todo en la región de Francia donde la
escasez está llegando un 41,6% es la
región de París que este fin de semana
estaba en una situación un poco mejor
pero hoy se agudizado la escasez de
combustibles Así que él ha sido más
cauto y ha dicho que para que todo se
normalice Es necesario por lo menos una
semana recordemos que al comienzo las
autoridades decían que todo iba a
normalizarse en pocas horas pero el
gobierno está haciendo un poco más cauto
en estos momentos Además mañana se va
una gran huelga general convocada por el
sindicato
cgt que ha de ya embarcado en este
movimiento a los sindicatos de la
energía de los servicios públicos de los
transportes por lo tanto las autoridades
están con la atención fija lo que va a
pasar mañana martes